thank you  and the warm-hearted  romanian people  for welcoming with open arms people  fleeing the war in ukraine  in this dark hour our unity and our  solidarity with ukraine  and the victims of this atrocious war  offer some light  romanians have given such a moving  example to the world  as the war started romanians were  rushing in droves to the vamassiret  crossing point  to welcome refugees with food water  blankets and baby milk  people are opening their homes for  families  they are organizing collections and  fundraising on social media  romania really has stepped up to welcome  the refugees and i really thank you for  that  you are a shining example of european  solidarity and i really want to commend  and thank you for that we will never  forget the solidarity of the romanian  people in this critical times